a severe with Grandmaster Alexander
Lenormand Alex you're playing in your
3rd US Championship and you are the 11th
seed out of 12 sometimes with a seed
that low we hear players say that their
goal is 50 percent do you have a higher
goal in that home well I try not to set
my goal as to you know result number
wise you know my only goal in this
tournament is to do the maximum that I
can in every game every move to try to
make sure I stay with my regime with my
plan to try to keep a clear head and
keep my inner peace we don't hear
players talk about the term inner peace
very much what do you mean by that
you're losing your you know calmness in
your heart you're you're starting to
think about too many other things and
getting distracted by other things which
isn't good when you're playing chess and
you're stuck inside yourself young we
have some players younger than you're
here but that's true but ok still I'm
only 22 and you know I feel like at
least until I'm 25-27 I can still you
know it developed quite a bit as a chess
player if I develop the right way I
think that's that matters much more you
know how you train how you develop what
you work on what terms you plan and are
you saying this is a career well I'm
trying to make it a career you know
right now I'm kind of I consider myself
kind of a student in the game like I'm
it's like i'm a student and trying to
become a professional i try to behave
like a professional but at the same time
i'm learning game you have much less
eager than a lot of strong chess players
well i don't know about that I don't
know about that
I try not to but that's that's not sure
I think all of us have to some ego and
you know that's that's something I try
to work on because I personally don't
think it's a good thing but you know so
I try to work on it but you know portion
i still do have some ego especially in
here last question have you retired the
letterman dance well I mean you know
we'll talk about it if if we need to
good luck at this really thank you very
much I appreciate